hi i'm elisa kelly i'm an astrologer
author and modern mystic
so i love tarot it is one of my favorite
mystical languages traditionally tarot
is 78 cards and these 78 cards tell
stories they are beautiful visual
depictions that you can use to
understand situations from more complex
more multi-dimensional points of view i
think that a misconception often with
tarot is that they are exclusively used
for fortune telling but that is actually
not how i use them i use them as a way
to explore
meditation to think about affirmations
and to really understand a situation
from this 360 comprehensive perspective
so oftentimes when you start to work
with a tarot reader they are going to
ask you for a question
the tarot reader should be able to help
prompt you and figure out how to ask the
best question but really
what you are going to want to
lead with is specificity so your
specific questions are going to be
responded to in very specific ways if
you are able to fine tune and really get
to the granular details of what you're
interested in knowing about if you just
bought your first deck of tarot cards do
not be overwhelmed the most important
thing is that you develop a unique
relationship with every single card in
the deck and how you're going to do that
is by getting to know all of the
different imagery and my recommendation
here is that each morning when you wake
up as part of your morning routine pull
a card and look in the little booklet
and do some reading about it and that
way each day you are going to be working
with a different story there's a
different archetype and gradually you're
going to be able to create connections
between your experiences your intuition
and the 78 cards in the deck as always
drew if you want to check out my work
head over to celebrity astrology
investigation on people tv and my new
show on spotify called astrology dating
[Music]